great I want to join PETA and welcome
everybody welcoming everybody here and
also thank PETA and Hackl ABS for
helping organize this really excited by
the turnout this is more than we could
have expected and also by the great
guest speakers who you'll be hearing
from in addition to me I have to go
through the Liggett ory recruiting pitch
you guys may have already seen makeshift
recruiting booth near the front we have
some great recruiting people here Alex
Tracy Jeff Kristina already to to talk
to you if you have questions so please
please make use of them basically
anybody in a lift t-shirt will point you
in the right direction if you're if
you're lost or looking for the right
person to talk to so I'm gonna make this
pretty quick and painless hopefully I
want this this one slide to essentially
do the selling for me hopefully and so
I've just assembled a few interesting
pictures of data science visualizations
that have come out of you know a handful
of the projects that we're working on
here and these are only the ones that
sort of lend themselves to these nice
pictures we work on a number of
different things but some of the things
you see represented here are supply and
demand balancing travel time estimation
fraud classification location estimation
and a number of other things yes sure
we'll do it thank thanks for the
heads-up so as I said these are just
some of the exciting problems we work on
I I think that this slide should speak
for itself in the sense that I challenge
you to find a company of our size who
has as diverse a set of data science
problems to work on on a day to day
basis I think we I think we take the
cake in that department so that's what
really drives the data scientists we
have working here and to handle this
diverse set of problems we we need a
diverse set of people so we have you
know data scientists from many different
academic backgrounds including
optimization and operations research
mathematics and statistics engineering
physics
you name it transportation science is
enough
big one so really excited to keep
growing the team and to have all of you
talk in more depth about about these
problems unfortunately I can't go into
much detail about these problems tonight
I'll be talking about something which I
hope is just as interesting but if you
are dying to talk about any of the data
science problems we have here you're
more than welcome to come back on
another day have lunch with us or you
know stay the whole day if you like five
hours or so and talk to a bunch of
people about all the nitty-gritty
details of these problems okay so so
what will I talk about we've tried to
organize a theme around experimentation
for two reasons one of them is that it's
something we can talk about somewhat
freely without giving away too many
secrets but I also think it's a it's a
very important topic and one which is
sort of given short shrift sometimes in
the data science community so this quote
is meant to be somewhat amusing it's a
quote from Fisher that I've sort of
modified to fit the times a little
better so I'll leave it up for your
amusement but the main point I'm trying
to make here is that I think we tend to
treat experimentation and a/b testing as
sort of a solved problem in in the tech
community and I think that's a
potentially dangerous mistake and so I'm
hoping that one thing you'll get out of
the talks tonight is a sense for what
some of the pitfalls are and some of the
things we need to watch out for and some
of the opportunities that we have as
data scientists to make big
contributions to make experimentation as
rigorous and as efficient as as it can
be okay so the particular area I'd like
to sort of dig into a little bit more is
what's technically known as statistics
as interference and this is something
which plagues experimentation in sort of
a marketplace setting like what we have
here at lift okay so here's a quick
outline I'll give you a very simple
example which I hope will kind of
motivate the problem I'll talk about
what this interference thing actually is
I'll tell you how we can use simulation
to sort of get a handle on how big of a
problem it is and then I'll try to
propose some ideas for for how to fix it
okay so here is pretty much the simplest
example that I could come up with it
imagines a sort of imaginary lift
universe where we only have
two passengers and one driver
unfortunately we're in an under supply
situation that is to say we don't have
enough drivers to satisfy all the demand
in this particular example and the sort
of treatment that I want to want to
think about in in the example and later
on in some of the other things in the
talk is what would happen if we were to
subsidize primetime so as many of you
know when we were in these under supply
situations we sometimes have to raise
prices that's called primetime pricing
let's think of it as just a binary thing
for this example and so what would
happen if we if lift paid primetime and
so the user did not have to worry about
paying this this this extra cost so
that's the the scenario I want to sort
of talk about so in as in any experiment
we would have a control situation and a
treatment situation so the control group
would be those who had who received
primetime as they normally would and so
we have to sort of have a model for how
those people would behave and so the
model I'm going to propose is that
imagine those people given that they
open the app and see primetime they're
going to take a ride with probability
1/2 so 50% chance they take a ride
50% chance they say no this is too
expensive I'm gonna use another option
ok so that's the control group the
treatment group would be those for whom
we paid the prime time and let's just
assume for simplicity that those users
would take a ride all the time 100% of
the time they opened up the app and see
no prime time they're taking a ride okay
so that's the basic setup and let's
assume that we have these two users a
and B they're equally likely to open the
app first they'll probably open the app
within a few seconds of each other so
very close in time all right so this is
the cartoon okay so in any experiment
there's usually a metric that we are
interested in in measuring so in this
case let's imagine it's the total rides
that happen on the on the lift platform
and so what we want to estimate is sort
of like in these two counterfactual
universes one in which everybody got
primetime and the other in which nobody
got primetime what would the effect on
the total rides we served be in other
words what would the difference in
expectation if you will be between the
number of rides served in these two sort
of parallel universes unfortunately we
can't observe both of those parallel
universes and that's where sort of it
the the purpose of experimentation comes
in
but we can in this case since we have
this model we can say exactly on average
what would happen in the two scenarios
and if you do a little bit of simple
probability and arithmetic what you see
is that in the global control setting so
that's all the the sort of pinkish box
on the bottom left where everybody gets
primetime in this under supply situation
the total number of rides you would
expect is 3/4 so slightly less than than
one ride on average the reason for that
is pretty simple you know either the
first person to open the app takes the
driver and that happens with probability
1/2 or the first user chooses not to
take a ride and then the second user
takes a ride also with probability 1/2
and so you end up with 3/4 so the the
blue box on the on the lower right
that's the global treatment scenario and
in that scenario it's much simpler
nobody has primetime the first user who
opens the app is guaranteed to take a
ride and that's that's the end of the
story second user is out of luck and in
that situation we expect one ride and
will always actually get one ride so
then if you compute an average treatment
effect between those two different
configurations so this is the thing that
I in the ideal world our experiment
would would estimate perfectly you see
that the by having my subsidizing prime
time in our treatment we've managed to
increase the expected number of rides by
33% so that is the that is sort of the
ground truth metric work we're after
here ok so now what would happen if we
just used a traditional naive a be
testing kind of framework and said let's
randomize half of our users to the
treatment half of our users to the
control and measure differences between
those two groups so in this situation
let's assume that means that passenger a
is assigned to the control gets
primetime passenger B is assigned to the
treatment and so we subsidize primetime
for passenger B okay so you have to go
through a little bit more arithmetic in
probability and this is sort of what
what pops out for the control user user
a they get primetime and there's a 50%
chance they open the app first 50%
chance the open they open the app second
so the only way for them to get a ride B
Osby will just steal the driver is to
both open the app first and also choose
to convert and so it works out to a 1/4
of an expected ride for passenger a in
comparison for passenger be the
passenger who doesn't have primetime
again two things can happen that that
user can either open the app first or
second if passenger B opens the app
first she'll always convert she'll get
the ride and if passenger B opens the
app second she has a 50% chance of still
having a driver available and and
therefore getting a ride and so you get
3/4 of a ride on average for passenger B
ok so what happens if you take a
difference between those two those two
numbers in relative terms you get an
estimated treatment effect of 200% so
now it looks like the treatment of
subsidizing prime time increases rides
by 200% on average per user obviously
this is wrong
and it's very different from the metric
we're after which is which we said was
33% okay so the question is what
happened and my claim is that this is a
very elementary example of what we'll
call interference and we'll talk about
in more detail but in sort of simple
terms in intuitive terms what happened
is that the the treatment that passenger
a got that is the fact that they saw
they got prime time actually helped on
the network level helped the overall
sort of ecosystem by helping to balance
the supply and demand ratio so because
user a saw prime time driver D had a
higher probability of sort of sticking
around longer and being available for
the next passenger so in this case even
though passenger B was treated with no
prime time that passenger got the
benefit accrued some of the benefit that
the prime time that a got sort of
generated for the system as a whole so
in other words AIDS prime time was kind
of like protective if you will to sort
of B's passenger B's ability to take a
ride successfully ok so here's a little
bit of more technical detail on on
interference if this is you know too
technical don't worry too much about it
but to talk about it sort of in
in in in more accurate terms you need to
think a little bit about causal
inference and a mechanism in causal
inference which is potential outcomes so
in causal inference you typically
imagine that every every unit every user
in this case or other experimental unit
has two possible outcomes one which
would happen under the treatment and one
which would happen under the control and
we only observe any one of those one of
those two potential outcomes for any
particular unit but we can imagine that
the true thing we want to estimate would
would correspond to the difference
between those two things
so here Z is a binary indicator that a
unit received a treatment and so what is
this notion of interference in third
bullet there's a definition and it's
quite a simple one it just says that the
potential outcomes these two values for
a given user or a given unit I actually
depends on the treatments that the other
units received
so here's Zed minus I is notation for
the sort of treatment assigned to the
other units so in the example we saw the
fact that you know passenger a got a
particular treatment affected the
outcome of passenger B and this leads as
we saw to estimators which are quite
biased and can be quite different from
what we were actually trying to estimate
so where this sort of originated in the
literature was in medical statistics and
they found that for vaccinations for
example this was a problem so if they
did a study where you know a brother and
sister one of them was assigned a
vaccination and one of them was assigned
like a placebo they found that the the
vaccination benefit somewhat accrued to
the to the person who got the placebo
because if your sister is less likely to
get the flu then you're also less likely
to get the flu and so on so a very kind
of analogous situation to what we saw in
the in the primetime example okay so
here are some some papers on this you
can look at these at your leisure I
think only the third one is kind of
interesting and I'll get into it in more
detail later okay so here is a just a
brief snapshot of sort of what are some
experimental designs that we can we can
use that lift or that sort of
immediately come to mind if you're
thinking about the kinds of experiments
that lift and similar companies would
like to do so the first one is
what we already discussed which is just
basic a be testing on users so like
randomized passengers or drivers or you
know users generally two different
treatment groups and what we saw in that
case was that we had a situation of
interference even in a very simple
example which caused some bias okay but
the good thing about this these user a/b
tests is that if we have a lot of users
which hopefully we do we have a small
variance and we can estimate that
variance very easily by doing some
simple resampling for example to get
those variance estimates so that's good
so the user the a/b testing that people
typically do is sort of on the bias but
low variance end of the spectrum sort of
in between there's a notion of spatial
randomization so since lyft operates on
a sort of a network on a map on it on a
literally on item on a map it seems
reasonable that we can subdivide space
like a city or a region into a bunch of
different spatial units and then
randomize those to different treatments
so I say that's somewhat intermediate
because as we'll see that has a bit more
variance than the sort of user a/b test
but it has less of a bias issue and
furthermore we can estimate the variance
pretty easily using some of the same
resembling ideas that you would use for
a per user randomization the third
bullet here is a type of design which I
think is somewhat unique to lift or
companies like lyft and that is the
notion of randomizing time intervals so
the idea here is you take a block of
time and you treat the entire network
with one particular experiment variant
for that block of time and then the next
block of time you swap to the other
variant assuming there's only two you go
from treatment to control or vice-versa
and then you keep alternating back and
forth between tribute and control for
successive time intervals until you run
it long enough and then you can
aggregate you know data from like like
treatment intervals together and try to
get some sense of the experimental
effect that way so we use these kinds of
things to sum to good effect I would say
as lyft
the great thing about these is they
don't suffer from the network
interference problem because in any
given time
you know modulo some edge effects or
some boundary effects all the users are
getting the entire network is getting
the same treatment but you do have to
just discard some data at the boundaries
of these of these blocks and the
variants in these experiments tends to
be quite large and the reason
intuitively is that you know blocks of
time can be very different so it may
rain for 15 minutes in a day and that
affects lives business quite a bit there
may be like a ball game that gets out
and one in one particular block of time
and that affects things and so you end
up with a lot of outliers and a lot of
just a lot of variants and probably just
as troubling as the the size of the
variance is the fact that there's no
real rigorous way that I know of at
least to estimate this variance in a
meaningful way and so that that makes it
very hard to get a handle on the various
metrics you're trying to estimate okay
so how can we sort of quantify these
this sort of bias bias variance
trade-off that I showed in the last
slide so we have a really great
simulation framework here I'd lift this
was built sort of jointly by the
different data teams I'd lift some of
you who attended the data ng-conf
conference that Pete spoke about may
have seen sort of a member of our Data
Platform team go into a lot of detail on
the simulator I won't go into much
detail except to say that it's you know
it was an early win for live data
science something we're really proud of
and we make tremendous use of and allows
us to you know test huge numbers of
algorithm of algorithmic changes without
necessarily running live experiments but
getting a sense for how they'll perform
it's backed up with you know predictive
models of user behavior and all sorts of
fun stuff uses production code highly
paralyzed on ec2 and so on but the goal
of this particular experiment was to
take that toy example I showed you and
actually run like a larger scale version
of that on actual lift historical data
but do the same basic treatment that is
subsidized primetime for some subset of
users and so the the three designs I
chose the three experimental designs I
chose to simulate were the firstly the
this sort of alternating time interval
design that I mentioned using our blocks
for simplicity and the second and third
were two different types of spatial
randomization so basically where I
divided cities into grids
and used either sort of a coarse or fine
grid in order to to choose units for
randomization so those are the three
different flavors I simulated I did 50%
treatment groups and also simulated the
sort of global treatment and control
which would give me the the s demand in
some sense the the true ground truth
metric that we wish to estimate okay so
here are some some brief results so I
actually looked at two rides so in
addition to the sorry two metrics that
is in addition to the the rides metric
that I discussed in the toy example I
also looked at something that's much
more of a network level metric and that
is ETA so for those of you who use lyft
you'll be familiar with that term but
it's simply the average pickup time that
a user can expect when they when they
open the app and that they see displayed
in the app so the story for these two
metrics is somewhat different so let me
talk through this these plus a little
bit the x-axis here is the ground truth
so this is what I got by running the
global treatment and the global control
comparing them so this is like the
x-axis is what we're trying to estimate
the y-axis is what we actually estimated
in each of these experimental designs so
ideally things would lie on that
diagonal gray y equals x line if
everything was working perfectly the
different colors correspond to the three
different designs I mentioned so the
purple is the time interval design pink
is a fine spatial grid and Green is a
coarse spatial grid and the the shapes
correspond to two different markets that
around the sin that's that's somewhat
less important okay so starting first on
the left hand side you can look at for
the the rides metric things are pretty
well behaved an increase in ETA s that
we observe when we when we subsidize
primetime in this way okay so this this
this slide summarizes basically the same
information you know in a bit more of a
compact way so here I'm just looking at
mean square error and saying like which
design gives the best mean square the
smallest mean square error in in in
these two metrics and you can see that
again there's a sort of a double story
here so for the rides metric it looks
like the spatial designs performed super
well and give lower root mean squared
error than the time interval based
approach and for ETA is it's it's sort
of dramatically the opposite so
as you can see the the fact that the
time interval based estimates were kind
of highly variable in a sense that there
were those separated punt clusters
doesn't matter as much as the fact that
the spatial designs were really biased
and we're giving up a big downward bias
and so in the ETA metric the time
interval based approach actually wins
right and so basically the takeaway from
this is that you know eta suffers from
this interference effect whereas Rides
doesn't suffer as much from the same
interference effect and therefore the
spatial designs do just fine but there
are kind of two takeaways here one is
that the the sort of design choice that
would be optimal among these three
depends on what metric and care about
and usually you care about a number of
metrics and so it's kind of hard to make
that decision even if you had these
similar simulation results as to which
metric you care more about the second
thing is that even though the the time
interval approach seems kind of safest
and mitigates this interference bias and
and seems to do reasonable things as I
said before it's it's very non-trivial
to estimate variance for that for that
type of design and so you may not even
know how well you've your experiment has
performed even if you chose chose this
design okay so to sort of wrap up I
thought I'd give some ideas towards a
way to get out of this conundrum using
some of the literature that I mentioned
earlier so there's this paper excited by
Hudgens and Halloran they do a very
causal inference based approach to this
where they try to essentially decompose
the total experimental effect that
you're trying to estimate into a pair of
terms one which they call a direct
effect and one would stay call an
indirect effect and if you take the sum
of those you'll end up with the total
effect which is essentially the average
treatment effect you're trying to
estimate so there's some math here it's
not super important I think what's more
interesting is the way that I chose to
design this simulation and that is as
follows with sort of a what they call a
two-stage randomization so essentially I
I did a hybrid approach between the
interval and spatial designs where I
first in each time interval I randomly
drew proportion a treatment proportion P
according
like just a uniform zero one thing and
then I randomized that proportion of the
spatial units to the treatment so in
every hour that's going to be a
different proportion of of units
sometimes like 90 percent of the spatial
units got the treatment sometimes 90
percent got the control and you know
everything in between and so then you
can measure or try to estimate these
direct and indirect effects just to give
you some intuition the direct effect is
essentially what you would estimate for
any given it's a function of the
treatment proportion here but for any
given design you can say okay what was
the difference between the treatment
units and the control units within that
design that gives you the direct effect
that's sort of the deny even like most
obvious thing you would measure on the
other hand an indirect effect asks the
question okay if I had two different two
slightly different designs so here
they're indexed by P and Q just two
different randomization proportions how
would a control unit look different in
those two designs so comparing control
to control but in two separate designs
how would that units outcomes or
potential outcomes differ and so if
there's no interference you can imagine
that that's that's going to be zero and
in most a B tests that's just assumed to
be zero okay and so then there's some
theory that says you can and it's really
just simple arithmetic it says you can
add these things up
take some limits assuming some
continuity and get an estimate of the
the total causal effect okay so this is
basically the last slide I tried to this
out in a simulation just to sort of see
how well it worked so these points
represent basically in bins of you know
point one treatment proportion on the x
axis what my estimates of the indirect
and direct effects for this treatment
this subsidized primetime treatment
would be and so this is now in an
absolute scale so the y axis is in
seconds of ETA and focused on the ETA
metric because that's the one where we
had this interference problem so so
these are the points I get I fit some
you know quasi principles curves to
these things and got something like this
which which may or may not be a little
bit judicious but we'll see for
reference the purple horizontal line is
actually the true
ground truth effect that we're after
based on you know doing the full
treatment and full control so that's
sort of the the thing that we're trying
to estimate and these broken purple
lines are what you get for the purely
time interval experiments so if you do
know spacial randomization just the time
interval as we saw there were two
clusters so these these two broken lines
correspond to those two clusters so you
can see they're quite far from the from
the ground truth but on average they're
right it's just that you'll never you'll
never observe the average you'll observe
one or the other and you have exactly
you know 50% chance of observing each
one okay so basically the the causal
effects analysis says easy just you know
add up the green the green curve and the
orange curve and as the the limit
approaches one you'll get your answer so
if you do that here you actually get
something quite close to the to the
treatment effect you're after so it's
just that the final point right there
and so it actually worked kind of
remarkably well in this in this example
now there are tons of caveats as I said
the curve fitting was somewhat somewhat
judicious as well I probably have more
data here than is realistic in some
scenarios so maybe the the true picture
is a bit noisier but I think that the
main takeaway I wanted to have here is
that by thinking a little bit more you
know cleverly and using some some causal
effects literature that's actually you
know fairly old we can potentially make
progress on this problem and come up
with experiments that are more efficient
for which we can efficiently and
successfully estimate the variants and
for which we can have a good idea of
what the true true causal effect of
interest is so I'm gonna I'm gonna end
it there
I have no no fancy concluding slide or
anything